Live-
Krer
in
H
[Musik]
AF
in
Public Viewing in [
Musik]
vorläufige
Maßnahmen
AF
Afrika
ja
Gambia
um
AF
[Musik]
für
G
nein
[Musik]
eine
für uns nicht
gegeben,
tut ihr Land nicht funktioniert  Ja,
[Musik]
ist eine
Inter-
Reform-
Hoca
für
Sh
H
Minister
Kumpel
Jo
in der Reihenfolge, in der das Gericht mit der
sofortigen Fortsetzung
anderer Arm-
Gruppen beginnt, die mehr
als folgen
Das Gericht
stellt nur dann fest, wenn die
Bestimmungen, auf deren Grundlage die
Juris-Angelegenheit, dass sie in Bezug auf
die Begründetheit des
Falles zuständig ist, zuständig sind
vom Antragsteller
in den Geltungsbereich dieses
Übereinkommens fallen können,
oder und sein
Inhalt stellt fest, dass Südafrika
angesichts des Umfangs und Ausmaßes
der militärischen
Operationen der Generalversammlung der Vereinten Nationen
am 12.
Dezember2
afrian
EV
afca stat in in ist
Das Gericht ist nicht nur der Ansicht, dass der
Teil unter der Aent Byra-Regierung für den 6. Dezember gegen Israel der Ansicht ist, ob
die von der Regierung beanstandeten Handlungen und Unterlassungen den
Bestimmungen
des Gerichts entsprechen. Das Gericht erinnert daran, dass Südafrika
Israel als
zu verhindern und zu bestrafen ansieht
REM
Standing of South Africa stellt fest, dass der
Beklagte
in dem Fall bezüglich der Anwendung
des Übereinkommens zur Verhütung
und Bestrafung von
Völkermord in
diesem
Zusammenhang mit den einschlägigen
Verpflichtungen nicht vor Gericht stand
bzw.
wendet sich das Gericht dann an die
Frage
meur gemäß Artikel 41
St, dass das Gericht
durch Maßnahmen die Rechte betreffen muss, die
nachträglich einer
Partei zuzurechnen sind, daher darf das Gericht
diese Befugnis nur dann ausüben, wenn es davon
überzeugt ist, dass die Rechte geltend gemacht werden  von
der Partei, die solche Maßnahmen beantragt, sind
in diesem Stadium des
Verfahrens zumindest plausibel, das Gericht wird jedoch nicht
gefragt, ob
zwischen
den Rechten, deren Schutz beantragt wird,
und den einstweiligen Maßnahmen ein enger Zusammenhang bestehen muss.
Das Gericht erinnert daran gemäß
Artikel  In einer der beiden Vertragsstaaten
haben sich alle Vertragsstaaten verpflichtet,
das Verbrechen des Völkermords zu verhindern und zu bestrafen.
Artikel 2 sieht vor, dass ich zitiere, dass
Völkermord jede der
folgenden Handlungen bedeutet, die mit der Absicht begangen werden,
eine nationale ethnische, rassische oder religiöse Person ganz oder teilweise zu zerstören
Gruppe als solche, die Mitglieder der Gruppe tötet,
B den Mitgliedern der Gruppe schweren körperlichen oder geistigen Schaden zufügt,
C,
der Gruppe vorsätzlich Lebensbedingungen zufügt, die geeignet sind,
ihre
physische Zerstörung ganz oder teilweise herbeizuführen,
D, Maßnahmen zur Verhinderung von
Geburten innerhalb der Gruppe ergreift  die Gruppe E erzwingt die
gewaltsame Überstellung von Kindern der
Gruppe in eine andere Gruppe Ende des Zitats
gemäß Artikel 3 der
Völkermordkonvention Die folgenden Handlungen
sind ebenfalls durch die Konvention verboten: Verschwörung
zum Völkermord, direkte und
öffentliche Aufforderung zum Völkermord,
Versuch des Völkermords und
Mittäterschaft  Bei
Völkermord sollen die Bestimmungen der
Konvention die
Mitglieder einer nationalen ethnischen, rassischen oder
religiösen Gruppe vor Völkermord oder
anderen in Artikel 3 aufgeführten strafbaren Handlungen schützen.
Das Gericht ist der Ansicht, dass
ein Zusammenhang zwischen den Rechten der
Mitglieder geschützter Gruppen besteht  Im Rahmen der
Völkermordkonvention werden die Pflichten, die den
Vertragsstaaten obliegen, und
das Recht eines Vertragsstaats, von einem
anderen Vertragsstaat die Einhaltung dieser Verpflichtungen zu verlangen,
wie das Gericht in anderen Fällen festgestellt hat,
damit Handlungen in
den Anwendungsbereich von Artikel 2
der Konvention fallen  Die Absicht muss darin bestehen,
zumindest einen wesentlichen Teil einer
bestimmten Gruppe zu vernichten. Dies erfordert die
Natur des Völkermordverbrechens,
da Ziel und Zweck der
Konvention als Ganzes darin besteht, die
vorsätzliche Zerstörung von Gruppen zu verhindern, auf die dieser
Teil abzielen muss  bedeutsam
genug sein, um Auswirkungen auf die Gruppe als
Ganzes zu haben, scheinen die Palästinenser
eine eigenständige nationale ethnische,
rassische oder religiöse Gruppe und damit eine
geschützte Gruppe im Sinne von
Artikel 2 der Völkermordkonvention zu sein, stellt das
Gericht laut
Quellen der Vereinten Nationen fest  Der Angriff auf die palästinensische
Bevölkerung im
Gazastreifen durch Israel
nach dem Angriff vom 7. Oktober 2023
hat zu zahlreichen Toten
und Verletzten sowie zur massiven
Zerstörung von Häusern, zur gewaltsamen
Vertreibung der überwiegenden Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung und zu erheblichen Schäden an der
Zivilbevölkerung geführt
Infrastruktur, während Zahlen
zum Gazastreifen nicht unabhängig
verifiziert werden können. Jüngste Informationen deuten darauf hin,
dass
25.700 Palästinenser getötet wurden,
über 63.000 Verletzte gemeldet wurden,
über 360 Wohneinheiten
zerstört oder teilweise beschädigt wurden und
etwa 1,7 Millionen Menschen
intern vertrieben wurden, stellt
das Gericht fest  Beachten Sie in diesem Zusammenhang
die Erklärung des Generalsekretärs der Vereinten Nationen
für humanitäre
Angelegenheiten und Nothilfekoordinator
Martin Griffiths vom 5. Januar 2024. Ich
zitiere: Gaza ist zu einem Ort des Todes
und der Verzweiflung geworden. Familien schlafen im
Freien, während die Temperaturen sinken  Den
Zivilisten wurde gesagt, dass
sie aus Sicherheitsgründen umsiedeln sollen. Sie sind unter B-
Bombardierung geraten. Medizinische Einrichtungen stehen unter
unerbittlichem Angriff
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation berichtete bei ihrer Mission im nördlichen Gazastreifen,
dass am 21. Dezember 2023, wie ich zitiere,
93 % der Bevölkerung des
Gazastreifens mit einem Hungerkrisenniveau
mit unzureichender Nahrung und einem hohen Maß
an Unterernährung konfrontiert sind. Ende des Zitats:
Das Gericht nimmt die
abgegebene Erklärung weiter zur Kenntnis  vom
Generalkommissar des Hilfswerks der Vereinten Nationen
für Palästina-
Flüchtlinge im Nahen Osten oder UNRA, Herrn
Philipe Lazarini, am 13. Januar
2024. Ich zitiere, es ist 100 Tage her, seit
der verheerende Krieg
nach den schrecklichen Angriffen begann und Menschen in Gaza getötet und vertrieben wurde
dass Hamas und andere
Gruppen gegen Menschen in
Israel vorgegangen sind Es waren 100 Tage voller Tortur und
Angst für Geiseln und ihre
Familien in den letzten 100 Tagen Die anhaltende
Bombardierung des Gazer Strip C
führte zu einer massiven Vertreibung einer
Bevölkerung, die sich im Wandel befindet
Ständig entwurzelt und gezwungen,
über Nacht wegzugehen, nur um an Orte zu ziehen, an
denen diese
kriegerische Milti
-Bevölkerung in
Gaza sowohl
psychisch als auch überfüllt und
unhygienisch ist. In den Notunterkünften leben mehr
als 1,4 Millionen Menschen. Ihnen mangelt es an
allem, von Nahrung über Hygiene bis hin zu
Privatsphäre. Die
Menschen leben unter unmenschlichen Bedingungen  Dort, wo sich
Krankheiten ausbreiten, auch bei kleinen
Kindern, leben sie unbewohnbar,
und da die Uhr schnell
in Richtung Hungersnot tickt, ist die Not der Kinder in
Gaza besonders herzzerreißend. Eine
ganze Generation von Kindern ist
traumatisiert und es wird Jahre dauern, bis sie geheilt sind.
Tausende wurden verstümmelt und
zu Waisen getötet  Hunderttausenden wird die
Bildung vorenthalten, ihre Zukunft ist in
Gefahr, mit weitreichenden und langfristigen
Folgen. Der Unre-
Generalkommissar erklärte außerdem, dass die Krise in
Gaza, wie ich zitiere, durch eine
entmenschlichende Sprache verschärft wird. Ende des Zitats
Diesbezüglich hat das Gericht dies zur Kenntnis genommen  Aus
einer Reihe von Aussagen hochrangiger
israelischer Beamter macht es
insbesondere auf die folgenden
Beispiele aufmerksam: Am 9. Oktober 2023 gab der
israelische Verteidigungsminister Yav Galant bekannt,
dass er eine vollständige Belagerung von
Gaza-Stadt angeordnet habe und dass es dann
keinen Strom geben werde  Kein Essen, kein Treibstoff
und dass
am nächsten Tag alles geschlossen sei. Minister
Galant erklärte, als er mit israelischen Truppen
an der Grenze zum Gazastreifen sprach
ist, wogegen wir kämpfen.
Gaza wird nicht zu dem zurückkehren, was es war, bevor es
keine Hamas mehr gibt. Wir werden
alles vernichten. Wenn es nicht einen Tag dauert,
wird es eine Woche dauern, es wird Wochen oder
sogar Monate dauern, dann werden wir alle Orte erreichen  Ende
des
Zitats vom 12. Oktober 2023: Herr Isaac Herzog,
Präsident von Israel, erklärte in Bezug auf
Gaza. Ich zitiere, wir arbeiten militärisch und
operieren militärisch gemäß den Regeln
des Völkerrechts. Es ist eindeutig
eine ganze Nation da draußen, die dafür
verantwortlich ist. Diese Rhetorik
über Zivilisten stimmt nicht  nicht bewusst, nicht beteiligt,
es ist absolut nicht wahr, sie hätten sich
erheben können, sie hätten
gegen das böse Regime kämpfen können, das
Gaza in Auda übernommen hat, aber wir sind im Krieg, wir
sind im Krieg, wir sind im Krieg, wir verteidigen unsere
Häuser, wir beschützen unsere  Häuser, das ist
die Wahrheit, und wenn eine Nation ihr
Zuhause schützt, kämpft sie, und wir werden kämpfen, bis
wir ihnen das Rückgrat brechen. Ende des Zitats vom
13. Oktober 20123. Herr Israel Katz, der damalige
Energie- und Infrastrukturminister
Israels, erklärte auf X vor Twitter. Ich
zitiere, wir werden  Bekämpfe die
Terrororganisation Hamas und vernichte sie. Die gesamte
Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza wird
angewiesen, den Gazastreifen sofort zu verlassen. Wir werden gewinnen.
Sie werden keinen Tropfen Wasser und keine
einzige Batterie erhalten, bis sie die Welt verlassen.
Zitat: Das Gericht nimmt auch eine
Pressemitteilung zur Kenntnis  vom 16. November
2023, herausgegeben von 37
unabhängigen Sonderexperten und Mitgliedern von
Arbeitsgruppen im Rahmen der
Sonderverfahren des Menschenrechtsrats der Vereinten Nationen,
in denen sie ihre
Besorgnis über die erkennbar völkermörderische
und entmenschlichende Rhetorik
hochrangiger israelischer Regierungsbeamter zum Ausdruck brachten. Ende
des Zitats  Darüber hinaus stellte
der Ausschuss der Vereinten Nationen zur
Beseitigung der Rassendiskriminierung am 27. Oktober 2023
fest, dass er
über den starken Anstieg rassistischer
Hassreden und Entmenschlichungen gegenüber
Palästinensern seit dem 7.
Oktober äußerst besorgt sei
kommen zu dem Schluss, dass zumindest
einige der Rechte, die Südafrika beansprucht
und für die es
Schutz sucht, plausibel sind. Dies gilt
im Hinblick auf das Recht der
Palästinenser in Gaza,
vor Völkermord und damit verbundenen
verbotenen Handlungen gemäß Artikel 3 geschützt zu werden
und das Recht Südafrikas, von
Israel die Einhaltung seiner
Verpflichtungen aus der
Konvention zu fordern, wendet sich das Gericht dann der
Bedingung des Zusammenhangs zwischen den
von Südafrika geltend gemachten plausiblen Rechten
und den beantragten einstweiligen Maßnahmen zu und ist der
Ansicht, dass dies ihrer
Natur nach zumindest einige davon sind  Die
von Südafrika angestrebten einstweiligen Maßnahmen
zielen darauf ab, die
plausiblen Rechte zu wahren, die es im vorliegenden Fall auf der Grundlage
der Völkermordkonvention geltend macht,
nämlich das Recht der
Palästinenser in Gaza,
vor Völkermord und damit verbundenen
verbotenen Handlungen, die in Artikel erwähnt werden, geschützt zu werden  3
und dem Recht Südafrikas, von
Israel die Einhaltung seiner
Verpflichtungen
aus der Konvention zu fordern, besteht daher ein Zusammenhang
zwischen den von Südafrika geltend gemachten Rechten,
die das Gericht für plausibel befunden hat,
und zumindest einigen der
vorläufigen Maßnahmen, die
das Gericht als nächstes beantragt  Zur
Frage der Gefahr eines irreparablen
Schadens und der
Dringlichkeit weist es darauf hin, dass es gemäß
Artikel 41 seiner Satzung
befugt ist, einstweilige Maßnahmen anzuordnen,
wenn ein irreparabler Schaden
für Rechte entstehen könnte, die Gegenstand
eines Gerichtsverfahrens sind, oder wenn eine
angebliche Missachtung dieser Rechte vorliegt  Rechte können
irreparable
Konsequenzen nach sich ziehen. Die Befugnis des
Gerichts, einstweilige Maßnahmen anzugeben,
wird jedoch nur dann ausgeübt, wenn
Dringlichkeit in dem Sinne besteht, dass eine
tatsächliche und unmittelbare Gefahr besteht, dass
den geltend gemachten Rechten irreparabler Schaden zugefügt wird,
bevor das Gericht seine endgültigen
Entscheidungen trifft  Die Bedingung der Dringlichkeit ist
erfüllt, wenn die Handlungen, die geeignet sind, einen
irreparablen Schaden zu verursachen, jederzeit eintreten können,
bevor das Gericht die endgültige
Entscheidung in dem Fall trifft. Das Gericht muss
daher prüfen, ob
in diesem Stadium des
Verfahrens eine solche Gefahr besteht. Das Gericht wird nicht angerufen  für die
Zwecke seiner Entscheidung über den Antrag auf
Angabe
vorläufiger Maßnahmen zur Feststellung des
Vorliegens von Verstößen gegen Verpflichtungen
aus der Völkermordkonvention, sondern um
festzustellen, ob die Umstände
die Angabe vorläufiger
Maßnahmen zum Schutz der Rechte
aus diesem Instrument erfordern, wie bereits erwähnt
Das Gericht kann zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt keine
endgültigen Tatsachenfeststellungen treffen und das
Recht jeder Partei, Argumente in
der Sache vorzubringen, bleibt
von der Entscheidung des Gerichts über den
Antrag auf Angabe
einstweiliger
Maßnahmen unberührt. Das Gericht erinnert daran, dass dies
im Beschluss der Generalversammlung hervorgehoben wurde
961 vom 11. Dezember 1946 Ich
zitiere:
Völkermord ist eine Verweigerung des
Existenzrechts ganzer Menschengruppen, so wie
Mord die Verweigerung des Lebensrechts
einzelner Menschen ist. Eine solche
Verweigerung des Existenzrechts erschüttert
das Gewissen der Menschheit und führt zu
großen Verlusten  zur Menschheit in Form von
kulturellen und anderen Beiträgen
dieser menschlichen Gruppen und
dies verstoße gegen das Sittengesetz und gegen den
Geist und die Ziele der Vereinten Nationen
Ende des Zitats
im Hinblick auf die Grundwerte, die
durch die Völkermordkonvention geschützt werden sollen, so
das Gericht  ist der Ansicht, dass die
in diesem Verfahren in Rede stehenden plausiblen Rechte,
nämlich das Recht der
Palästinenser im Gazastreifen,
vor Völkermord und damit
verbundenen verbotenen Handlungen gemäß
Artikel 3 der Völkermordkonvention geschützt zu werden, und
das Recht Südafrikas, die Einhaltung der Bestimmungen durch Israel zu verlangen  Die
Verpflichtungen dieser Staaten im Rahmen der Konvention sind
so beschaffen, dass ein Schaden, der ihnen droht,
während des andauernden Konflikts irreparablen Schaden verursachen kann. Hochrangige
Beamte der Vereinten Nationen haben wiederholt
auf die Gefahr einer weiteren
Verschlechterung der Bedingungen im
Gazastreifen aufmerksam gemacht, die das Gericht zur Kenntnis nimmt  Als Beispiel
für den Brief vom 6. Dezember
2023, in dem der Generalsekretär
der Vereinten Nationen dem Sicherheitsrat die folgenden
Informationen zur Kenntnis brachte:
Ich zitiere: Das
Gesundheitssystem in Gaza bricht zusammen.
Nirgendwo ist es in Gaza sicher, da
die israelischen Streitkräfte ständig bombardieren
Und ohne Unterkunft oder das Nötigste zum
Überleben gehe ich davon aus, dass die öffentliche Ordnung
bald zusammenbrechen wird, weil die
verzweifelten Bedingungen selbst eine
begrenzte humanitäre Hilfe
unmöglich machen. Eine noch schlimmere Situation könnte sich
entwickeln, einschließlich epidemischer Krankheiten und
erhöhtem Druck zur Massenvertreibung
in die Nachbarländer, die
wir sind  Angesichts der ernsten Gefahr eines Zusammenbruchs
des humanitären Systems verschlechtert sich die Situation
schnell zu einer Katastrophe
mit potenziell irreversiblen
Folgen für die Palästinenser als Ganzes
und für den Frieden und die Sicherheit in der Regon-
Region. Ein solches Ergebnis muss
um jeden Preis vermieden werden. Ende des
Zitats zu 5  Im Januar 2024
schrieb der Generalsekretär erneut an den
Sicherheitsrat, in dem er über den aktuellen
Stand der Lage im Gazastreifen berichtete und
feststellte, dass die
Zahl der Todesfälle und Zerstörungen, die ich zitiere, bedauerlicherweise verheerend ist.
Ende des Zitats: Das Gericht nimmt auch
die Erklärung vom 17. Januar 2024 zur Kenntnis
Der UNRA-Generalkommissar bei seiner
Rückkehr von seinem vierten Besuch im
Gazastreifen seit Beginn des aktuellen
Konflikts in Gaza. Ich zitiere jedes Mal, wenn ich Gaza
besuche, werde ich Zeuge, wie die Menschen immer
tiefer in Verzweiflung versinken, während der
Kampf ums Überleben jede
Stunde in Anspruch nimmt. Ende des
Zitats  Das Gericht ist der Ansicht, dass die
Zivilbevölkerung im Gazastreifen
weiterhin äußerst gefährdet ist. Es erinnert daran,
dass die von
Israel nach dem 7. Oktober 2023 durchgeführte Militäroperation unter anderem
zu Zehntausenden
Toten und Verletzten sowie zur Zerstörung
von Häusern, Schulen, medizinischen Einrichtungen und
anderen lebenswichtigen Einrichtungen geführt hat  Infrastrukturstruktur
sowie Vertreibung in großem Ausmaß
Das Gericht stellt fest, dass die Operation noch
andauert und dass der
israelische Premierminister am 18. Januar 2024 angekündigt hat, dass
der Erste Krieg noch viele lange
Monate dauern wird  Der
Gazastreifen hat keinen
Zugang zu den grundlegendsten Nahrungsmitteln,
tragbarem Wasser, Strom, lebenswichtigen
Medikamenten oder
Heizung. Die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation hat geschätzt, dass
15 % der Frauen, die im Gazastreifen gebären,
wahrscheinlich
Komplikationen erleiden werden, und weist darauf hin, dass die
Mütter- und Neugeborenensterblichkeit hoch ist
Aufgrund des mangelnden
Zugangs zu medizinischer
Versorgung wird unter diesen Umständen mit einem Anstieg gerechnet. Das Gericht ist der
Ansicht, dass die katastrophale
humanitäre Lage im Gazastreifen
ernsthaft Gefahr läuft, sich
noch weiter zu verschlechtern, bevor das Gericht sein
endgültiges
Urteil fällt.
Das Gericht erinnert an die Erklärung Israels,
die es abgegeben hat  bestimmte Schritte, um
die Bedingungen
der Bevölkerung im
Gazastreifen anzugehen und zu lindern. Das Gericht stellt außerdem fest, dass der
Generalstaatsanwalt von Israel kürzlich
erklärt hat, dass ein Aufruf zur vorsätzlichen Schädigung
von Zivilisten eine Straftat darstellen kann,
einschließlich der Aufstachelung, und
dass mehrere solcher Straftaten vorliegen  Fälle werden
derzeit von israelischen Strafverfolgungsbehörden geprüft. Solche Schritte sind zwar zu
fördern, sie reichen jedoch nicht aus, um
das Risiko zu beseitigen, dass ein irreparabler
Schaden entsteht, bevor das
Gericht seine endgültige Entscheidung in dem
Fall fällt. Angesichts des Vorstehenden geht das Gericht davon
aus, dass dies der Fall ist  Dringlichkeit in dem
Sinne, dass eine tatsächliche und unmittelbare
Gefahr besteht, dass
den Rechten ein irreparabler Schaden zugefügt wird, den das Gericht
vor seiner endgültigen Entscheidung für plausibel gehalten hat.
Das Gericht kommt auf der Grundlage der
oben genannten Erwägungen zu dem Schluss, dass die
von ihm geforderten Voraussetzungen erfüllt sind
Es ist daher gesetzlich vorgeschrieben, dass das Gericht angeben muss, dass einstweilige Maßnahmen getroffen wurden.
Bis zu
seiner endgültigen Entscheidung muss es daher
bestimmte Maßnahmen zum
Schutz der von Südafrika beanspruchten Rechte angeben,
die das Gericht für plausibel befunden hat.
Das Gericht erinnert daran, dass es dazu
befugt ist  gemäß seiner Satzung, wenn ein
Antrag auf einstweilige Maßnahmen gestellt wurde,
um Maßnahmen anzugeben, die ganz
oder teilweise von den im
vorliegenden Fall beantragten abweichen, wobei das Gericht die
Bedingungen der
von Südafrika beantragten einstweiligen Maßnahmen und die
Umstände des Falles berücksichtigt hat
stellt fest, dass die angegebenen Maßnahmen
nicht mit den beantragten identisch sein müssen.
Das Gericht ist der Auffassung, dass
Israel im Hinblick auf die gegenwärtige Situation
im Einklang mit seinen Verpflichtungen
aus der Völkermordkonvention in
Bezug auf die Palästinenser in Gaza
alle in seiner Macht stehenden Maßnahmen ergreifen muss, um
die Begehung von zu verhindern  alle Handlungen im
Sinne von Artikel 2 des Übereinkommens,
insbesondere a Tötung von Gruppenmitgliedern
der Gruppe b Verursachung schwerer körperlicher oder
geistiger Schäden an Mitgliedern der Gruppe C
vorsätzliche Zufügung
von Lebensbedingungen, die geeignet sind, die
physische Zerstörung der Gruppe insgesamt herbeizuführen
Das Gericht erinnert daran, dass diese Handlungen
in den Anwendungsbereich von Artikel 2
der Konvention fallen, wenn sie
mit der Absicht begangen werden,
die Gruppe als
solche ganz oder teilweise zu zerstören  ist ferner der Ansicht, dass
Israel mit sofortiger Wirkung sicherstellen muss,
dass seine Streitkräfte keine
der oben genannten
Handlungen begehen. Das Gericht ist außerdem der Ansicht, dass
Israel
in seiner Macht stehende Maßnahmen ergreifen muss, um
die direkte und öffentliche Anstiftung
zum Völkermord in diesem Zusammenhang zu verhindern und zu bestrafen  an die
Mitglieder der palästinensischen Gruppe im
Gazastreifen ist
das Gericht außerdem der Ansicht, dass
Israel sofortige und wirksame Maßnahmen ergreifen muss,
um die Bereitstellung
dringend benötigter Grunddienste und
humanitärer Hilfe zu ermöglichen, um die
widrigen Lebensbedingungen der
Palästinenser im
Gazastreifen in Israel zu bewältigen  muss außerdem wirksame
Maßnahmen ergreifen, um die Zerstörung zu verhindern und
die Beweissicherung
im Zusammenhang mit Vorwürfen von Taten im
Rahmen von Artikel 2 und Artikel 3
der Völkermordkonvention gegen Mitglieder
der palästinensischen Gruppe im
Gazastreifen im Zusammenhang mit der
von South beantragten einstweiligen Maßnahme sicherzustellen  Afrika, dass Israel
dem Gericht einen Bericht über alle Maßnahmen vorlegen muss, die zur
Umsetzung der
Anordnung ergriffen wurden. Das Gericht erinnert daran, dass es
gemäß Artikel 78 der
Gerichtsordnung die Befugnis hat, die Parteien aufzufordern,
Informationen zu allen
damit zusammenhängenden Angelegenheiten bereitzustellen  Umsetzung etwaiger
einstweiliger Maßnahmen, die das Gericht
im Hinblick auf die konkreten
einstweiligen Maßnahmen, die es indiziert hat, angegeben hat, ist der
Ansicht, dass
Israel dem Gericht innerhalb eines Monats ab dem Datum einen Bericht
über alle Maßnahmen vorlegen muss, die zur Umsetzung
dieser Anordnung ergriffen wurden
Gemäß dieser Anordnung wird der so
bereitgestellte Bericht dann an
Südafrika übermittelt, das
Gelegenheit erhält, dem Gericht seine
Kommentare
hierzu vorzulegen. Das Gericht erinnert daran, dass sein ORD
keine vorläufige Wirkung hat und somit
internationale rechtliche Verpflichtungen für jede
Partei schafft, an die die vorläufigen Maßnahmen gerichtet sind
angesprochen werden, bekräftigt das Gericht, dass die
im vorliegenden Verfahren ergangene Entscheidung
in keiner Weise die
Frage der
Zuständigkeit des Gerichts für die Entscheidung in der
Sache oder etwaige Fragen im Zusammenhang mit der
Zulässigkeit des Antrags oder
den damit verbundenen Begründeten präjudiziert
Unberührt bleibt das Recht der Regierungen
der Republik Südafrika und des
Staates Israel, Argumente
zu diesen
Fragen vorzubringen. In der Anordnung heißt es dann, dass das
Gericht es für notwendig erachtet, hervorzuheben,
dass alle Parteien des Konflikts im
Gazastreifen an diese gebunden sind  Das
humanitäre Völkerrecht ist zutiefst besorgt
über das Schicksal der Geiseln, die
während des Angriffs in Israel am 7. Oktober
2023 entführt wurden und seitdem von der Hamas und
anderen bewaffneten Gruppen festgehalten werden, und fordert ihre
sofortige und bedingungslose
Freilassung. Ich werde nun den
verfügenden Teil verlesen
Aus diesen Gründen weist das Gericht
die folgenden vorläufigen
Maßnahmen an: Eins mit 15 zu zwei Stimmen: Der
Staat Israel wird in Übereinstimmung mit
seinen Verpflichtungen aus der Konvention zur
Verhütung und Bestrafung des
Verbrechens des Völkermords an den
Palästinensern und Gaza alle ergreifen  Maßnahmen
in seiner Macht, um die
Begehung aller Taten im Sinne
von Artikel 2 des Übereinkommens zu verhindern,
insbesondere a Tötung von Mitgliedern der
Gruppe b c Verursachung schwerer körperlicher oder
geistiger Schäden an Mitgliedern der Gruppe C
vorsätzliche Zufügung
von Lebensbedingungen für die Gruppe berechnet
seine physische Zerstörung ganz
oder teilweise herbeizuführen und Maßnahmen zu verhängen, die
darauf abzielen, Geburten innerhalb der
Gruppe zu verhindern, zugunsten von Präsident Donahue,
Vizepräsident, gorgischer Richter Tomka Abraham
Bona Yousef SCH Bandari Robinson
Salam iwasawa nte Charlesworth Brandt
Jud Adak M gegen Richter Seend Richter
Adak
Barack mit 15 zu zwei Stimmen wird der Staat
Israel mit sofortiger
Wirkung sicherstellen, dass sein Militär keine der
in 0.1 oben beschriebenen Handlungen begeht, zugunsten von
Präsident Donahue, Vizepräsident, Georgia,
Richter, Tomka Abraham Bona, Yousef, Sh
Bandari, Robinson, Salam, Iwasawa und
Charlesworth, Markenrichter, Edak
M  gegen Richter
Barack mit 16 zu 1 Stimmen. Der Staat
Israel wird alle in
seiner Macht stehenden Maßnahmen ergreifen, um die
direkte und öffentliche Anstiftung zum
Völkermord an zwei Mitgliedern der
palästinensischen Gruppe im Gazastreifen
zugunsten von Präsident Donu zu verhindern und zu bestrafen  Vizepräsident
Gorgian Richter Tomka Abraham Bona Yousef
SCH Bandari Robinson Salam Iwasawa Nte
Charlesworth Brand Ad-hoc-Richter Barack
Msen gegen Richter
mit 16 zu 1 Stimmen abgesegnet Der Staat
Israel soll sofortige und
wirksame Maßnahmen ergreifen, um die
Bereitstellung dringend benötigter
Grundversorgung und humanitärer Hilfe sicherzustellen  Hilfe zur
Bewältigung der widrigen Lebensbedingungen, mit denen die
Palästinenser im Gazastreifen konfrontiert sind,
zugunsten von Präsident Donahue,
Vizepräsident, gorgischer Richter Tomka Abraham
Bona Yousef SCH Bandari Robinson Salam
iwasawa nte Charlesworth Brandt Richter
Adoc Barack M gegen Richter
mit 15 zu
zwei Stimmen im Bundesstaat  Israel ergreift
wirksame Maßnahmen, um die
Zerstörung zu verhindern und die
Beweissicherung im Zusammenhang mit Vorwürfen von
Taten im Rahmen von Artikel 2 und
Artikel 3 des Übereinkommens zur
Verhütung und Bestrafung des
Völkermordverbrechens an Mitgliedern der
palästinensischen Gruppe sicherzustellen  Gazastreifen zugunsten von
Präsident Donu Vizepräsident Georgien
Richter Tomka Abraham Bona Yousef CH
Bandari Robinson Salam Iwasawa nte
Charlesworth Brandt Richter Edak M gegen
Richter Seed Richter Edak
Barack mit 15 zu zwei Stimmen Der Staat
Israel soll dem Gericht einen Bericht
über alle Maßnahmen vorlegen  Es wurde beschlossen,
diese Anordnung innerhalb eines Monats
ab dem Datum der
Anordnung zugunsten von Präsident Donahue,
Vizepräsident Gorgan, Richter Tomka Abraham
Bona
Yousef Bandari Robinson Salam iawa no
Charlesworth Brandt, Richter Adak M,
gegen Richter Edak
Barack, den ich jetzt anrufen werde, in Kraft zu setzen  der
Registrar, um den Tenor des
Befehls auf
Französisch zu lesen
Den
Jo
KR
frei
[Musik] [
Musik]
Gefühl
krer do für
[Musik]
t
für
beginnen
[Musik]
für
Gefühl